Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Game of Thrones we got some more callbacks
to the Iron Bank of Braavos, Syrio Forel’s
unknown status and Sansa in the Vale.
But really I feel like all the energy was
at Crasters.
Quick heads up to, if you’re finding me
for the first time I do weekly Game of Thrones
videos with all kinds of bonus stuff.
This week is round 5 of my giveaway.
All you have to do is participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment.
Because I’m getting ready to hit 200,000
subscribers just as a way to say thank you
I’m doubling it.
So I’m picking two random people from the
comments to give giftcards to.
So let’s talk about love triangles and the
moon door.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here are my top 5 WTF moments, Number 5 - Lysa
and Littlefinger
In case you don’t remember from Season 1,
she is looney tunes crazy.
Mostly crazy for Littlefinger.
It’s kind of tragic how much he’s taken
advantage of her lifelong obsession with him.
But here are the cliff’s notes on their
historic love triangle with Catyln Stark.
Littlefinger loved Catlyn as a boy, but she
like most teenagers wasn’t always crazy
for him.
Her younger sister Lysa became obsessed with
him.
Because Littlefinger couldn’t have Catelyn,
he took Lysa as consolation prize.
He basically took her virginity.
Only making her obsession worse.
But she was forced to marry the much much
much older John Arryn who ruled The Eyrie.
John Arryn discovered Joffrey was a bastard
but Littlefinger who was working a long con
at the time, used Lysa’s obession to get
her to poison her husband slowly and send
that letter to Catelyn that made her think
the Lannisters were responsible.
Which is part of the reason Catelyn took Tyrion
to the Vale to be executed in season 1.
That was only the half of things in the Vale
in the episode, we can unpack the freaking
hilarious sex screaming in the comments.
But the big takeaway from Sansa this week
is that Lysa looks like she could flip out
and try to do something awful to her.
Keep you eyes peeled on Lysa.
Robin Arryn, her son.
Is like a crazy Joffrey analog.
He’s just crazy at the opposite end of the
spectrum.
Who else felt awful for Sansa when he just
farted out his mouth about the Red Wedding?
Number 4 - You Can’t Run From The Iron Bank
This may not have seemed like a big deal,
but I think this Iron Bank plot will become
a much bigger thing in a few episodes.
But how surprised were you when Tywin Lannister
said all their gold mines had been exhausted.
They’re still rich, but there’s no new
money coming in.
All those wars that he funded and the money
he lent to Robert also took a huge chunk of
their wealth.
So that’s why they need the Tyrells.
They’re the only other super wealthy family
in Westeros right now.
Mark Gatiss is playing someone from the Iron
Bank, but no word on which episode he’ll
debut in.
It actually seemed like there were a lot of
big call outs to Braavos in the episode.
Number 3 - Daenerys Does What Queens Do
I liked the casual way Daario talked about
taking Meereen’s fleet of ships.
It’s basically enough to carry the force
they have right now to Westeros.
So technically if they wanted to, they could
probably take the Iron Throne and enough people
would just flock to her banner to help them
subdue the rest of Westeros.
They wanted it to feel like Daenerys could
go either way.
But in doing so, all of her good work freeing
slaves would be undone.
So she’s sticking around.
But her enemies are starting to come back.
They name dropped Cleon, a former Slave who’s
taken over Astapor.
He’s going to be important so remember him.
Back in Yunkai the Wise Masters took power
back.
So they’re also going to be a group Daenerys
will have to face again.
We didn’t see the dragons, but I expect
we’ll see them again soon.
Number 2 - Brienne and Podrick world’s best
Odd Couple, next to Brienne and Jaime
Yes, it’s a bummer that Jaime is there with
her, but I love the comedy they brought to
the episode.
When the whole world is burning or freezing
around you it’s nice to get some relief.
She’s slowly warming up to him but it was
really when she learned about how Pod saved
Tyrion from the Kingsgaurd at Blackwater that
sealed the deal.
I feel like this also foreshadowed Pod saving
Brienne at some point this season.
He’s not super at cooking rabbits but he’s
there when you really need him.
I also loved the way they visually connected
Pod talking about running his spear through
the back of the kingsguard’s skull and the
way Jon Snow killed Karl.
and my number 1 WTF moment, no surprise here
- Jon Versus Karl
We’re going to miss you Burn Gorman, you
were an amazing villain.
In case you were wondering, he died inside
Craster’s Keep and because they lit it on
fire, I think he burned too.
So he won’t come back as a Wight.
The fight scene was pretty amazing too.
There is a lot of swordplay or water dancing
in Arya’s case.
But we don’t get really pitched intimate
battles like this very often.
I thought David and Dan did a really good
job of developing Karl as a villain so that
this final fight felt like such a high point.
That shot of Jon’s sword though.
That will go down as one of the all time best
killing blows on the show.
Not quite as big as Ned Stark’s beheading,
but definitely Top 5.
Now it’s your turn, let me know what your
favorite moment was.
Jon and Karl, Arya and the Hound or Sansa
in the Eyrie?
Because there were so many big things going
on, here’s some notes on things we also
have to pay attention to:
Arya is water dancing again and she let the
hound know he’s on her list of people to
kill.
I was so happy that Needle couldn’t penetrate
his armor.
I love the two of them as a pair.
They’re like the anti Pod and Brienne.
Or Pod and Brienne are like the anti Arya
and the Hound.
Let’s just call them Team Fuck the King.
The Hound also had a big wink to the fandom
about Syrio Forel.
Everyone always wants to know whether he’s
dead or not, and the Hound thought that Meryn
Trant couldn’t kill himself with his own
blade if he tried.
So if you believe him, that means Syrio is
still alive.
In reality, George RR Martin never said what
his fate was in the books.
And in every interview I’ve ever seen he
refuses to say for certain what happened to
Syrio.
So let me know whether you think he really
died or not.
Then let’s follow up with Bran, it looks
like he’s back on track to find that giant
weirdwood from their visions.
Poor Hodor too, did you see the look on his
face when he realized he killed Locke.
And then there was the major Sand Snakes namedrop.
Oberyn talked about his 8 daughters.
I know a lot of you have been asking me if
we’ll see any of them this season.
Based on the pacing of the episodes and given
the fact we’re halfway done with the season,
I don’t think the show will bring them on
until Season 5 at the earliest.
If there’s anything important that you thought
I didn’t mention, just write it in the comments.
Overall the episode was a solid A minus.
They did an amazing job of paying off the
Karl plot, which was developed beautifully
even though he wasn’t even in that many
scenes.
I think Burn Gorman really nailed evil.
I hope he plays some more villains in the
future.
He looked like he had so much fun.
The way they revealed the Vale and the Eryie
was also really breathtaking.
You go from the Bloody Gates, this horrible
claustrophobic Kill Box to that big panoramic
CG shot of the castle at the top of the mountain.
The idea is that Sansa is supposed to be safe
from armies there, but because of crazy pants
Lysa and Robin, she’s probably in just as
much danger as she was in King’s Landing.
Emotionally the Bran breakaway at the end
didn’t land with me, mostly because I know
the book canon and Bran never went to Caster’s
in the books, so the whole subplot was a little
surreal to me.
But Jon’s reunion with Summer was so good.
It probably touched me so much because I’m
a dog person, I’ve had big Labrador Retrievers
my whole life.
So I know what it’s like to love a big animal
like Summer.
I didn’t expect them to try and top the
White Walker scene from last week.
But Karl’s death came pretty close.
I felt like the whole Meera thing was building
towards them dying a horrible death, so it
wasn’t a huge surprise that Jon stabbed
him in the back of the skull.
Podrick Style.
Let me know if you have any other lasting
questions about the plot or what’s coming.
Next week based on the teaser Tyrion’s Trial
starts.
So I’m really excited to watch that play
out.
My Q&A will post tomorrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
One more time, thank you so much you guys
for helping me get to 200,000 subscribers.
You’re all awesome.
Right now click here for that Q&A, i’ll
add the annotation as soon as i post it.
And click here to learn all about the last
war with the White Walkers and the building
of the Wall.
See you guys tomorrow, high fives!
Everybody go hug your dog if you have one.